hi i'm kasia and i'm a beauty blogger
and makeup artist and i'm going to be
showing you today how to get the perfect
smoky eye so if you want to know how to
create this look keep on watching I love
a good smokey eye if I want to impress
this is a look to go for I'm going to
show you a really easy to follow smoky
eye with a pop of color and something
that lasts all night if you're going for
a look that's gonna while everyone you
don't it coming off halfway for the
night so I'm going to be using the Tarte
cosmetics lid lock eyes shadow primer
when you're going for a smoky eye you
don't need to worry too much about the
color of your primer because the lighter
is the more the colors are gonna pop so
I'm going to be using the Urban Decay
Born to Run eyes shadow palette and I'm
just going to use a really beautiful
smoky orange color for my crease just
gonna pop the color on and then I'm
gonna blend and repeat I think that the
eyes are the windows to the soul
I think they're one of the most
important features on the face so
wide-open Hance
your features
don't worry if your eye shape is a
little different to mine whether you
have a big crease whether you have a
small crease doesn't really matter as
long as you're putting your color first
and you can see it through the smoky eye
that's the rest important thing so once
you've done that I'm gonna go in now
with some cream eyeshadow a really dark
brown I'm gonna use my one from Laura
Geller and you just want to put that all
over the base so that's gonna help to
create a really smoky look just go for
that all over my lid and then gonna
blend out there's a lot of blending
involved with smokey eye because if you
don't get the blending right it's not
going to look as amazing as it would
otherwise
so brushes are really important when
you're doing a smoky eye very very
essential or that you have at least one
blending brush one pencil brush and a
flat eyeshadow brush those I think of
three essential brushes and if you have
those do any eye look so smoky eyes you
can really dictate how intense you want
your eyes to be I'm going to be adding a
lord and very black eyeliner pencil all
around my waterline just to add a little
bit more intensity just to put it on my
waterline and I'm going to blend it with
my brush so I'm blending my black line
up quite high however if you have less
lid space then you can just keep closer
to the waterline also when I'm putting
eyeliner in my waterline I put it on the
top as well this just creates a little
bit more intensity
we went from lukewarm to smokin hot so
I'm just gonna clean up the sides of my
eyeshadows simply by using a little bit
of concealer on my brush this is perfect
if you get any eyeshadow fallout or if
you're quite a messy eyeshadow
applicator so now I'm going to be
putting on my false lashes because no
smoky eye is complete without some good
lashes right and I'm going to be using
our delt wispies I just find the putting
mascara on before you put your lashes
you can get a really seamless lash line
you can pinch them together and it also
gives the lashes more volume top tip for
putting lashes on is to look down into a
mirror and then to place them onto your
lash line
to finish I'm just going to add some
highlights in the corner of my eyes just
to make the smoky eye pop thanks for
watching this video I really hope you've
enjoyed and you've got some cool tips
and tricks on how to create the perfect
smoky eye don't forget to comment on
this video and share with your friends
who might need some new tips too and
make sure you subscribe to glamour UK's
YouTube channel to see more videos like
this
[Music]